certains ont l'impression de courir
après le printemps depuis des semaines
enfin il se pointe le bout du nez ç'a
pris du temps avant qu'ils commencent à
faire assez chaud pour qu'on n'ait envie
de venir courir
il arrive au bon moment pour moi je
viens d'arriver sur montréal depuis un
mois et petit à petit ça monte et non
non c'est très bien dimanche matin les
coureurs sont partout sur les sentiers
du parc lafontaine et certains mettre
les bouchées doubles pour reprendre le
temps perdu
vous en avez l'habitude s'affaisse bien
on se défoule définitivement du retard
mais aussi de sentir coupables de ce que
supervisé par rapport à sochaux c'est
quoi ce pas raisonnable s'entraîner plus
fort et plus intensément ne s'est pas
sans risque
de nombreux coureurs se retrouvent dans
des cliniques de physiothérapie au
printemps ces deux athlètes du dimanche
n'a rien fait durant sa saison morte et
que la semaine allait trop vite trop
fort dans son entraînement essaie de
réparer les blessures de sur utilisation
mais il met un stress beaucoup trop
élevé par rapport à ce que ces
structures peuvent lui donner le temps
dont les périodes les os les muscles
[Musique]
se fixer des buts trop rapide ou trop
ambitieux par exemple pour un marathon
et un danger bien réel
faut vraiment vraiment vraiment essayé
délai d'une progression lente mais
satisfaisante pour se mettre près faut
pas avoir peur non plus d'écouter son
corps pour moi ce qui est important
c'est pendant la course et après la
course le lendemain de la course
est ce que je suis rien est-ce que j'ai
des blessures est ce que j'ai des
douleurs
si oui elle devrait écouter mon corps en
pis ne pas progresser
après tout mieux vaut courir lentement
que pas du tout pour profiter pleinement
de l'été qui s'en vient ici antoine
diers du canada montréal